okay i think we'll go ahead and and get
started uh my name is ben kickert and
i'm here with my colleague marine bear
um we'll be looking over the the chat so
if you have your path bullet
you can interact with her over there the
session that we will be presenting today
is entitled creating vr learning rooms
with wolfram
and a-frame as i'm sure many of you have
also
experienced during this time of coveting
quarantine lots of things have changed
for our team one of the things that
we've been exploring a little bit more
has been virtual reality looking into
the advancements
that have happened over the last couple
years and also looking at ways that
we can implement it into some of the
work that we've done
previously um because of our uh interest
in in the wolfram platform
one of the things that we've been
looking into is unique ways
that we can use the wolfram stack to
create vr spaces
in our case we're wanting to develop vr
learning rooms
that allow us to automate and simplify
the creation
of vr settings that can bring data in
that you can learn if you're more of a
spatial learner or a visual learner
as opposed to being on your phone for
another hour or two
excuse me we want to give you a more
interactive way that
you can do that and so we're looking to
do that through
a process involving a frame which we
will
talk about uh now
but before we do that the first thing um
just to touch base on or to
to mention um is the state of virtual
reality and what's happening and i feel
that
um nearly every uh meeting or conference
or speaker that i hear talk about
virtual reality
every one of them says that you know
this is the year that vr
is going to explode and i guess that i'm
no different
when i say that i think that that we are
at a tipping point
if we look at some of the big players uh
pricewater's house cooper
um has said that nearly 23.5 million
jobs worldwide will be using
um uh augmented reality and virtual
reality by 2030. so there's an
expectation that that will be included
as part of regular um workspace
engagement
we've seen vr meeting apps just in the
months between march 2020
and june 2020 again due to quarantine
we've seen a 10-fold
increase in how meeting apps are are
being used
from a hardware and software side uh
we're seeing that market move from 6.2
billion dollars in 2019
uh to 16 billion dollars uh projected
for
2020. and part of the reason i think
this is happening is because we're
starting to see
a positive feedback loop we're reaching
a point where
standalone headsets and and pc based
solutions
are more available or of higher quality
that's leading to more people adopting
which then leads to better game
development better app development
and as more people develop more users
become interested so a couple things
that are happening that are exciting for
us
um if you followed along um in in some
of the news about vr
probably the biggest announcement is the
launch of the oculus quest 2
which is a 300 unit that is an
all-in-one
you're not tethered to anything and you
can have six degrees of freedom
while you're using that if you look at
advancements on things like the
vive index what you see is is a
incredibly high quality user experience
that people are able to tap into
using all of the graphics processing
power of their their units
you're seeing for the first time true
aaa game development
we've seen that in half-life alex which
again contributes to
that positive feedback loop if you look
at wolfram when you look at
the discussions that we've had about
virtual reality in the past
there's actually already a body of work
that exists that goes back for um five
or six years if not longer
um probably the most notable one uh is
the unity link
that integrates with the unity engine
allowing you to create
3d scenes and then export those as apps
that can work
on vr headsets um pedro francisco
i did an exploration back in 2016 which
i find fascinating with those four
years ago talking about ways that
wolfram can be used
in that vr environment about how we can
use it look at volumetric shapes how we
can interact with
items and use vr um four years ago his
his conclusion was
it wasn't quite mainstream i'm hoping to
talk to him to see if he's uh he's
changed his mind at all
another link that i want to provide was
a recent
wolfram language uh presentation that
can be viewed on youtube
going through how that unity engine
integration can work
with ar and with vr
now looking at um the the options that
have been out there particularly the
unity engine
um this is a separate set of software um
that requires a a particular skill set
to be able to integrate um you're having
to work
back and forth between the two units
between the two software packages so
what we wanted to look at
is an implementation known as a-frame
now a-frame is going to be based on
3js it's a javascript library that
allows you to create
using simple html 3d scenes that can be
both viewed
on on a laptop which we'll do here as
well as on a headset
it's open source it's community
developed it's free
so as opposed to having you having to
use a separate software package
we've looked at a-frame as our option
because we can
automate and do everything in a totally
text-based
way just using a code editor and in our
case
doing some automation with wolfram one
of the things that a-frame works with
is it has a lot of library add-ins and
so
in addition to the main package you can
also include physics packages
look at object interactions how you can
add environments which we'll talk about
today
as well as some of the controller
integration for the different vr
headsets
um the strength is obviously that it's
it's free um we'll take a look at the
code it's very simple to do
um it's useful for the desktop and the
vr is a crossover
um one of the challenges that we've run
into or some of the challenges
is that there's varying quality of the
libraries and documentation if you're
comfortable
in javascript and html probably not an
issue for you
but if you're looking for a turnkey
solution it might not be
the best choice we've seen also some
significant changes in the framework and
in browser implementation
that have caused some of our previous
working code to break um it's also
dependent
not only on an internet connection but
on browser functionality
this has been an issue as with oculus
quest you're bound to whatever browser
they
they put in there and so if if they
change their render engine
um it can cause issues with uh with the
implementation
so the first thing i want to do is look
at a very basic
a-frame script um again if you're
familiar with html
you this should look very familiar to
you in terms of setting attributes
um open and closing tags um here we're
opening an html document
we are giving it a title we're importing
the a-frame
script which makes everything else
possible below it
once we open the body we simply say you
know we want an a
scene which is the um the code
that a-frame uses and we want the
background color to be a light blue
let's put a box in there and we want
that box to be positioned and we give
the three coordinate system for that so
your xyz
coordinate so negative one is going to
be to your left point five is going to
be
up by half a meter and negative three
will be three units
in front of you you can set the rotation
the color um and then simply close that
tag
we do the same thing for a sphere and
the same thing for a cylinder
and then we'll put a a plane on
the ground for us close the scene and
we're done
now because all of this is html based
you have
many options on on where you can deploy
this you could simply export your html
put it up onto an ftp server and it's
ready to go in this case
but because we're at a wolfram
conference and we want to showcase the
ways that wolfram can be used
we're going to use cloud export so if we
we click our link
here and again i'm this is the
the web-based version we can actually go
full screen
and you can see with just a few lines of
code
we now have a 3d scene if you were in
your oculus quest
or another vr headset every direction
you look
you could you could see what was going
on and interact with
the space as well
but simply taking existing html code and
publishing it to the wolfram cloud as an
html file
by itself is not particularly useful so
what we wanted to do is look at some
automation for steam creation
and so here what we've done is we've
started creating some html chunks
so we start with a simple open which
we've already shown
and then we're going to have a simple
close just closing the scene in the body
in this case we want to have a larger
floor so we create that manual element
that we're going to include
but from the the wolfram side one of the
strengths of the wolfram
software packages are that you can
randomize and you can also
intentionally place things very easily
and so for us
we can ask wolfram to give us 10 random
colors to add a little bit of variety to
our scenes
here's a bit of code that i have
borrowed from stack exchange
and i'm thankful for that but this
essentially takes the wolfram colors
and converts it to hex so that we can
implement it into
our html we also want to create random
sizes so in this case we're going to
create a
simple scene with 10 random spheres and
so
we ask wolfram for those 10 random
numbers same thing for our x coordinate
position our y coordinate position and
our z coordinate position
um with that using a string join
we can take all of that and create these
units so if you're looking for a
randomized scene
you want to have trees in different
places you want to have
different objects to interact with that
that don't have to be placed manually
with a few lines of code we can create
that um
pull all of that together into our html
and again we will
publish that to the cloud um and so here
you see your your 10 random scenes or
use 10 random spheres
so our idea is to explore some of these
options so that when we get into the vr
learning side of things
we can automate things that are that are
going to be useful
for us now the next thing i want to look
at is the intentional placement of
objects
so let's say that you want to create a
scene where you're standing in the
middle and you can look around and there
are things that are equally placed in
all directions around you
again this is a generic example but
let's just take the numbers 1 to 15.
we want those in a circle 4 meters
around us
and evenly spaced out so using wolfram
we'll we'll calculate what degree
each of those items needs to be rotated
so that it faces the center of the
circle
using circle points um we can create our
coordinate system
that's going to go ahead and give us the
uh the left and right
um and forward and back coordinates the
the x and the z
and then we'll say we want everything to
be one unit um raised
create the elements uh just as we did
before
but in this case we want to add a little
bit more uh texture and flare
so we're gonna take a 360 degree image
that we've pulled off of the free site
unsplash
we want to export that up to the cloud
so it's available for us
add the code so that you can add the sky
to your scene
and we can assemble that scene here
and so now using wolfram we're able to
place
all of those items in a organized and
evenly spaced manner the other option
you can do
is to create a hallway this is
is probably the setting that we use the
most just because it's
it's easier to interact with and so
we're going to use our random
colors again calculate where those
things need to be what what is the depth
of our hallway going to be
how far to the left how far to right how
far back does each item need to be
placed
in which direction does that need to be
rotated so that um
it's facing what we need we'll create
those objects again essentially the same
code that we've used previously
but in this case as we're kind of adding
more elements to our scene and to our
work
we want to look at a few of those
additional libraries that could be
useful to us and so in this case we're
going to look
at the a-frame environment component
which allows you to import the
javascript and then
with a single entity create a scene
around you
that is much more realistic than um than
just having a blue sky and a black floor
we're also going to use a-frames extra
which allows us to create navigational
meshes
so that as we're walking up and down the
hallway you're not wandering
in places that isn't useful for the user
so for that to work
we're going to update the opening of our
html by adding the two javascript
packages
we're going to define our environment in
this case you can see that we're saying
we want the environment
to be the preset of forest we want a
relatively open play area
so that nothing gets in the way and you
can set how many trees you want
in your forest and we want a flat ground
we're also going to create a rig
which is simply an entity that moves
collectively
and so in our case the the rig that
we've created will contain the camera
and some of our more advanced
implementations what we'll do is take
that same
rig and include our oculus controllers
so you can interact
with things we also put a light within
the rig so that if you're walking down a
dark hallway
you get that effect of being able to see
a few meters one direction
or the other i mentioned the
navigational mesh but in order to
um calculate that we're pulling in um on
some of the strengths of wolfram saying
you know we know how many items we have
we need to make sure that that the mesh
that will constrain
us gives us space forward and backwards
and then it's it's evenly placed um
and so that can be used uh with with
that uh we can then assemble
that and here again this is is more of a
simple example but now we can walk side
to side it won't let us
move left or right um you can see the
the scene around us with the trees that
we've
selected and when we reach the end of
the hallway
um we we can turn and head back the
other way again if you were in a vr
headset all of that would be interactive
as you as you move
around
now the title of our of our presentation
is vr learning rooms
and looking at color swatches isn't
particularly useful for that
so instead i want to share with you a
little bit of how we actually use this
as a way to provide a
learning environment that is useful for
people who are more spatially or
visually oriented
this last slide and we will update we
will upload our entire notebook
to the pathable site so you can use it
you will be able to open this slide
make the decisions that you want about
your room um
and then submit the entire thing and you
can create a vr
world in in a matter of minutes um but
in this case we're just gonna call it a
vr
learning room we're gonna define a page
title um we can decide how
wide we want our hallway to be because
in this case we're going to be using
images
to interact with i give users the option
to randomize those images so depending
on how you bring those in
it might be more useful to have them
randomized and then i give you the
option
to either have this published to the
cloud or publish to your wolfram
directory um locally and so if you're
doing something with videos you're doing
something with a lot of images
it might be easier for you to export all
this to your computer and then upload it
to your
ftp server or if you choose wolfram
cloud true
it will publish and be available that
way
as well so here we're giving users the
option for the environment
i tend to like a very simple light
environment and so i've defined my
my properties and arguments this way but
if you want any of the presets
we used forest previously but you can
you can try
any of these out here is actually all of
the options
that you can change uh within your
environment so if you want to start
tweaking things and change your lighting
or change your shadows
this gives you the option to do that but
the real question and the reason that
the title of this slide is content is
king
is because we really want to be able to
bring in information
that is not only neat but but is useful
um and so the example that i want us to
look at
is actually something that brings us
here to a web seminar is the fact that
we're we're dealing with coping 19
and we need different ways to interact
um and so the first thing we're going to
do is just a simple image search
for covet 19 infographics as those come
in we're going to resize those and so
here we have 10
infographics that have come into uh that
we will put into our scene
i've included a couple other ways that
we internally
have done other searches and actually we
have a presentation
um immediately after this one where
we're really looking at
other ways to find and source and
utilize visual information and to turn
unstructured data into visual
information
but let's say that we want two images of
of these topics that we're interested in
this gives us the option to do that
let's say that you want to
search for multiple aspects of a search
term so my daughter is 11 and a huge
harry potter fan
so she can look for her favorite
characters and say that she wants a
profile picture of them
as well as the cartoon character version
of them and so if she does this search
um you know again a a couple presses of
a button and she's created her own
vr world where on the left hand side is
a profile picture of harry potter and on
the right
um we have the the cartoon character um
if you have a bunch of files in a folder
you can pull all those in um same way if
you want a random subset
of those um now our code is getting
a little bit more complicated because
now we're having to deal with additional
assets to
our scene so what this is doing is it's
it's actually creating the images um it
is then
exporting it either to your local
directory or to the wolfram cloud
but because you've already defined all
the images
again simply run this and it will rename
all of your files and it will go ahead
and put it either into your local
directory
or into your uh your wolfram cloud
account
now one of the things that's different
when you start dealing with images and
video
is there is a need to pre-load your
assets
so we'll look at what the code looks
like but essentially
i'm going to pull that one out
but essentially you're going to um load
all of your assets list them as preload
um so that when you actually open up
your scene and make sure that everything
is in place before you
uh before you actually run things and so
um that is going to take
the images that you you've uploaded so
here you can see they're all
in my wtc wolf from wr learning room
assets
that have been renamed sequentially in
terms of the images
just like what we did this is
essentially the same code
as what we have with the color swatches
but we're going to calculate all the
positions
of those images we're also going to add
the source name
which is which is simply going to call
from uh the files that we created um so
that we can use the anchor
in in the assets um again just like
we've done before
all of these uh entities are now created
um the the program tells you where
things are gonna be placed
um we've added to um the the height
that it automatically adjusts for the
aspect ratio of the image so everything
here is going to have a constant width
of two units
and then the height is going to be based
on the image itself so you can see that
that has been
auto updated we're going to add a page
title
to our scene create our navigational
mesh pull everything together and
publish it
to the cloud so here
you see our first vr learning room
again all of this is just coming in from
a google image search
um but if it's if you're one of those
people who
you know memorizes things by remembering
where they're at in relation to things
um being able to walk through this is a
little bit more enjoyable than just
sitting on the couch with your your
phone and and scrolling through things
now i am aware of our time um i i do
want to see if we have time for at least
a few questions if not i'll
i'll catch up after my next session in
the in the chat bar
um but i do want to show a few things of
extra credit
um these are not things that i'm sharing
in the code with i'm happy to if you
reach out to me
um but a few additional projects and so
one of them that we've looked at
is bringing in wolfram 3d models and so
there you have your triceratops
and your your teapot that we can use
um i can leave that up we also have
this has image interaction and so in
this case we pulled in
um all of the sustainable development
goals and we've made it so that when you
mouse over it we auto-generated audio
um so it simply says what the sdg is but
this could be anything you could
have a picture of shakespeare and pull
in a quote from him but when you mouse
over it
you're gonna hear what it is and you can
see the interaction as things
um move up and down another
implementation of the same code
uh would be to take what you have um to
take a to
say you take a a picture of a state um
and when you mouse over it it's going to
tell you what the
employment rate is um if you take the
time and positioned everything exactly
uh you could actually have the image pop
up in front of you and actually create
those uh interactive displays we've also
done a video hallway
that you can walk down and just like
with the images you can watch the videos
as they as they come in
so what's the conclusions and the next
steps my conclusion is that i i think
that
um vr is is only going to grow
especially as we're looking for new ways
um to to interact um in in a quarantine
world or in a virtual world
um we're seeing lots of development
we're seeing that positive feedback loop
next i think that the wolfram stack
particularly in something like this
provides a good solution for auto
generating code whether you want it
randomized or whether you want
pattern-based attributes i'm showing it
on how you can use this for
a-frame but this could be used for you
know generating
your own website or generating c
c code or or python you can use the same
idea
if you're having to implement things in
a in a different way
for us with html it works well um we've
looked at a bit
at how vr adaptations are coming along
and some of the things that we've talked
to some of the people that we work with
is how easy it is
if you want to have a 360 degree video
tour of your
um of your campus um once you have the
the video which is relatively easy to
obtain
um it's a single line of code that says
a video sphere close a video sphere
and and you can do that we're looking
particularly with these alternative
learning environments for people who are
probably be more excited by having a vr
headset on
than they are scrolling through google
image search
so for us the the next steps um as we
mentioned i'm i'm
about to duck out of here and join our
next session at 3 p.m
which is using wolfram to find and
analyze unstructured data and so we'll
look at everything from
more advanced uses of image search using
some machine learning
to help find the best images automating
twitter and pulling in twitter for
information
that can be utilized not only for vr
learning rooms but for
summaries of unstructured data and so
you're welcome to join us
over there um we're also going to look
at ways that we can integrate what we've
done
into a multi-user experience um similar
to what the work being done
in a frame by mozilla labs is and then
finally the next
things are to utilize more of the
development data
the last two years that we've presented
we've talked a lot about what's
happening in sustainable development
we want to be able to take that same
interest
and parlay it with virtual reality to
get more people excited and interested
in it
and then finally we touched on it with
our triceratops and our teapot
but we do want to add a bit more of what
pedro actually looked at with 3d objects
within wolfram and how they can be used
in a in a vr scene
so that is the end of my formal
presentation within the next
hour i will upload it into our pathable
file list
and so if you want to check back you're
welcome to it welcome to use the code
adjust the code
um it's there for you so hopefully if
you have kids or friends or family
they'll find it just as interesting to
be able to
do a quick search and and create their
own vr world
i know we've had a lot of fun with it um
uh
looking at uh just some of the comments
in the chat thank you for that feel free
to continue that
um again i i think that we're looking at
a high school educator
uh who could use this because of the way
this is structured we actually have
uh you can do the same thing with an api
you can do the same sort of thing
with wolfram api or with a cloud deploy
um to where you could
um have either wolfram code or wolfram
code in the back end
so that all that your users have to do
is create a search
um and the world will be created for
them um so it's a lot of our options
with that so
thank you uh thank you all so much for
your time um i don't see any specific
questions but
feel free to reach out to me um and
we'll go from there
appreciate your time